this is Tim Ferriss hello everybody I am
going to show you one of my favorite
tricks this is something you do just
about anywhere a handful of these
doesn't require a lot of gimmickry or
goodies it just requires a toothpick or
a match preferably flat sided this is
round if you don't have that you can
also use a key then you need a spoon
fork and any glass really will do so
this is how it works this is a physics
trick actually it's just physics but
it's fun to watch so you have to
interlace the fork and the spoon like so
not every restaurant will like this so
you start with that
and all you're going to do in this case
it's tooth pick so you can see you're
sticking in the side within the
semicircle effectively and then you can
balance it on the side of the glass here
and I'll show you what this looks like
it's like that
you look at it from the side you can see
if you have a match for the number of
matches you can actually burn both sides
down so that it's fairly barely hanging
on it's quite cool in this case if you
move it I encourage you to keep your
hand underneath it so if it's a key
it'll often slide into the water but you
can see you won't have your hand
oftentimes you can move it around anyway
that's trick enjoy